cette semaine en quête le mystère de la
mort des deux chefs bélanger en
thaïlande
regardez l'écart cinq jours ont semblé
redonner aux autorités de canadiens que
c'est cacher quelque chose
l on puisse avoir un jour la cause de ce
g d'accueil ou dans nos consoles de jeux
de mots s'est dit plus
what you elle m'a dit non tout tester
et doit-on mettre fin au système des
paradis fiscaux qui permettent aux plus
riches de payer très peu d'impôts le
truc consiste à déclarer un maximum de
profits dans les pays où l'impôt est
faible le parlement à ottawa et le
gouvernement washington permettent tout
ça c'est ça de scandale
[Musique]
bienvenue en quête la mort des deux
jeunes québécoises dans un hôtel en
thaïlande survenu en juin dernier a
bouleversé tout le monde mais ce qu'il
ya de pire pour des parents c'est de ne
pas savoir ce qui s'est passé
tout ce que l'on sait c'est que la mort
de noémie et audrey bélanger s'inscrit
dans une série de morts mystérieuses en
thaïlande et au vietnam
une de nos équipes s'est rendu en
thaïlande un mois après la mort des deux
jeunes québécoises pour explorer
différentes pistes enquête sur un
mystère qui ne cesse de s'épaissir en
voyage en asie audrée et noémie bélanger
arrive à koh phi phi le 12 juin une île
paradisiaque au sud de la thaïlande une
île reconnu pour sa vie nocturne
cette nuit du 12 juin sera leur dernière
après avoir fait la fête dans les bars
noémie et audrey rentrer à l'hôtel
elle n'en ressortiront pas vivante on
les retrouve mortes dans leur lit deux
jours plus tard
que s'est il passé
[Musique]
à
depuis leur décès mille questions
torture l'esprit de la famille bélanger
linda karl et elena l'aîné ont accepté
de collaborer avec nous dans l'espoir de
trouver des réponses
ils ont déjà une piste à la suite du
drame plusieurs personnes nous ont
contactés pour leur dire que leur fille
ne sont pas les seuls que d'autres
touristes sont morts de façon
mystérieuse en thaïlande
et chaque fois les pesticides ont été
évoqués karl bélanger est convaincu que
les pesticides ont tué ses filles
le genre d'homme au repos je changerai
pas d'idée c'est l'épaisseur
il s'agirait d'un pesticide qui serait
utilisé en thaïlande dans les chambres
d'hôtel contre les punaises de lit
nous avons suivi cette piste en
thaïlande pour tenter d'élucider le
mystère et permettre aux parents de
comprendre la mort subite de leur enfant
samedi 16 juin à 8h30 du matin les
parents sont inquiets et sont sans
nouvelle des filles depuis cinq jours le
téléphone sonne
c'était un adversaire à jo pour vous
inquiéter et médias non ce nouvel os qui
s'est passé quelque chose labo géant
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit le
jeu commence à peine quelques ce qu'ils
ont dit bon ben il y aurait retrouvé
deux canadiens commencent avec deux
canadiennes mort dans une chambre d'hôte
a dit oui mais l'eau a toujours des
canadiens et des québécois genre pied
adipi 10 l'aja tv ils disent 25le dans
ma tête j'ai fait ou de sa douce ans
j'ai fait aux lacets comme tout arrêter
je savais que maman était menaçable cam
entendait parler puisqu'elle est inquiet
et je raccroche et lbg raccrocher je
devais ok c'est bon alerte alerte je
pourrais savoir un retard et gémit
téléphone à côté donc là c'est un peu la
panique de qu'est ce qu'on fait dans des
situations comme ça donc on savait
qu'ils étaient au courant
en gros on a appelé la sûreté du québec
assq québec pas au courant non plus là
on est vrai le pur quoi ça parle aux
nouvelles cia pour personne qui est au
courant
là on a vu cette expo alors si on le
sait pose pas ce poison on a appris il
nous autres escales et on a appelé
l'ambassade et leur ambassade ont dit on
n'a pas les résultats on va faire des
recherches plastiques attendant un art
pour savoir si tu tes enfants sont mal
et il me tue à celles d'autres
convaincre que ces poisons
moi c'est ce que je pense et montage
face à montanes dire non regarde elle
présente c'est peut-être présente on se
passait depuis ma part c'était de voir
arriver un taux de police un autre
patrouille c'était ça je ne faisais que
ça je faisais laissant podor
j'avais le téléphone des mains je
faisais les sens pour j'attendais
l'appel l'ambassade
je guettais la police puis je criais
l'ena je veux pas car il veut pas car et
je veux pas car et c'est juste ce qu'on
fait on essaie de croix jusqu'au dernier
moment que c'est pauline haute et j'ai
dit elena il faut appeler fois plus
l'ambassade moi je suis plus capable
d'attendre faut je le sache mais là
l'ambasseur de monde ils vont bien
adapté pour le pôle droit de faire
sauter les faux mais étant donné le
temps c'est ça fait longtemps que
j'attendais dont wolf arrive donc le
je vous confirme le décès de noémie
audrey bélanger
c'est à ce moment que le père des filles
karl bélanger arrive arrive à côté de
mandy l'écarlate ils ont trouvé les deux
films dans le champ mental dans le monde
je parle de la carte jetons bataille
âgées
[Musique]
revenons sur le voyage d'audrey et nos
ennemis elle quitte le québec le 18 mai
pour un voyage d'un mois au vietnam et
en thaïlande
après quelques jours à bangkok elle
arrive à krabi
de là comme le font des centaines de
jeunes tous les jours elles prennent le
bateau le 12 juin en milieu d'après-midi
pour lille de pipi
une île sans voiture un dédale de
ruelles des hôtels bon marché
elles rejoignent jeff et luciano deux
frères brésiliens qu'elles ont
rencontrées au vietnam qui sont déjà à
pipi comme en témoignent leurs échanges
de courriels alors ma chère comment ça
va nous sommes arrivés à pipi nous avons
trouvé un hôtel pour 24 livres sterling
qui est assez bien
il est à cinq minutes de la plage et des
barres elles prennent finalement une
chambre dans le même hôtel que les
brésiliens
en soirée ils se rendent ensemble ou
slinky barre
c'est la fête sur la plage tous les
soirs à pipi
viviane possibile et élise turcotte font
la connaissance de noémie et audrey on a
vu une fille qui marchait dans l'eau
noemi avait bu un peu plus puis j'ai
l'impression qu'elle avait besoin d'un
peu de son espace
j'ai demandé à ce que ça veut bien me
dis aime regarder car fait ça va fuck
you may j'ai dit ok on vous voyez que
nous imite un peu plus seul parti avait
un verre de plus dans la maison
sauf qu'elle s'élabore c'est normal nous
aussi on avait à voir dans les puits
audry aussi mais un peu moins que muni à
une heure du matin les deux filles
accompagnées des deux brésiliens rentrer
à l'hôtel
[Musique]
quarante huit heures plus tard on
retrouve les deux soeurs mortes dans
leur lit
pendant ces 48 heures les deux
brésiliens s'inquiète alors ma chère
comment vas tu es tu toujours à pipi je
veux te revoir j'appelle attachante mais
tu ne réponds pas je prends l'avion
prend comme le 17
j'aimerais te revoir avant de partir est
toujours vivante
je suis triste de ne pas avoir revu le
13 juin
jeff glisse un message sous la porte de
la chambre des filles qui dit i'm sorry
il s'excuse mais de quoi
jeff et luciano sont les derniers à
avoir vu les filles vivent les parents
leur ont écrit il aurait tant de
questions à leur poser et deux garçons
ne leur ont jamais répondu nous avons
retracé jeff à londres à nous aussi il a
refusé de parler qu'à la can est ma dès
la découverte des corps les autorités
thaïlandaises écarte toute piste
criminelle et parle plutôt
d'intoxication alimentaire il pourrait
s'agir d'un poisson le fugu qui se vend
très cher et qui peut être mortelle
jetables en voyage avec noémie milliards
pour le plus gros con de manger dans
notre un mois et demi de voyage chez 5
dollars donc un poisson à 300 dollars
qui est toxique l'autonomie c'est sûr
que non un empoisonnement alimentaire
pain vont réagir de la même façon s'il a
une qui a revu sa soeur malade malade
malade
l'autorité chargée de live auxerre
départ du matin des touristes leur ont
appris qu'il y a eu d'autres décès
mystérieux à pipi et on entre en
communication pour nous expliquer que la
même chose s'était produit et c'était
similaire que c'était des bruissements
qui sont décédés qui ont pas eu le temps
de se rendre à l'hôpital
mais les deux sont décédés et puis était
dans le champ du fait que je me dis ça
peut-être en rapport avec la charge
en 2009 dans cet hôtel de pipi le la
lina cas ça use deux femmes une
norvégienne est une américaine sont
mortes à deux jours d'intervalle dans
deux chambres adjacentes
la cause de leur décès n'a jamais été
élucidé a chiang maï dans le nord de la
thaïlande
six touristes et un guide thaïlandais
sont morts l'an dernier sur une période
de deux mois dont quatre dans le même
hôtel le downtown in le ministère de la
santé publique en thaïlande n'y voit
qu'une coïncidence joker lankais
thaïlandais a révélé que deux décès
pourrait être relié aux pesticides
un autre un virus quant aux quatre
autres morts on en ignore la cause
plusieurs familles ont critiqué le
sérieux des enquêtes thaïlandaise
parmi les quatre victimes qui logeait au
d'entendre in se trouvait sarah carter
une néo zélandaise
âgé de 23 ans
la télévision de la nouvelle-zélande est
allé enquêter sur place hélas pris des
prélèvements dans la chambre où a logé
sa raquette après analyse l'enquêté a
conclu que les pesticides utilisés dans
l'hôtel contre les punaises de lit était
encore cet hôtel le d'antonine moderne
est en bon état a été démolie cet été
sans qu'on sache pourquoi
[Musique]
les punaises de lit sont un problème
dans les hôtels en thaïlande comme
ailleurs le 6 juin une semaine avant
l'arrivée des deux soeurs un touriste
s'est plaint sur un blog du tout une
pomme résidence l'hôtel où les filles
sont mortes
il écrit qu'il est déçu de cet hôtel
qu'il y avait tellement de punaises de
lit qu'il a eu du mal à dormir avec tous
les courriels qu'on a eu c'est des
pesticides sur le noun moi j'ai tout un
dit probablement j'ai dit qu'ils ont le
client d'avant à du spleen qui avaient
des puces de 10 octobre des punaises de
lit puis lyon et j'ai dit on saupoudre
et le matelot puis ont probablement
remis découverte là dessus de saas et sa
peau respirer jeudi les filles on
arriver le soir d'ennui que son pilote
ça ça ma thèse
ok des hypothèses soit en brie bella
puis pouf et on respire et s'appuient on
peut on se sont même pas lui demander de
l'aide ce salon salon les photos où j'en
trouvais paraît tous les deux touchés
dans l'ue lit dans l'oubli comme celle
de remercier de leur mairie
au bout de l'île un aubergiste français
installés ici depuis 25 ans demande à
son personnel de vaporiser de
l'insecticide deux fois par jour contre
les moustiques
[Musique]
mais que ce soit pour les moustiques ou
les punaises de lit l'utilisation des
pesticides n'est pas réglementée en
thaïlande
mais les deux personnes à la fois c'est
un peu un peu dur avant l'école c'est
pas une piste se serait pas une piste
écartée est ce que nous en europe avant
de bannir des tas de produits on en a
utilisé d'état que tel qui ici il ya des
produits qui sont utilisés
il ne devrait plus l'être
après la pause des contradictions qui
s'accumulent je pense que si deux
personnes avaient été infectées par un
insecticide d'autres aussi le reiki
[Musique]
a t'on aspergé de manière exagérée les
chambres
au moment de notre passage opentrust
dance la chambre sont mortes les deux
filles est en restauration
on s'est débarrassé des vieux matelas
les nouveaux attendent dans le couloir
nous louons la chambre au dessus la 203
nous voulons savoir si l'hôtel utilisent
des pesticides pour éradiquer les
punaises de lit et si oui lesquelles
et en quelle quantité avant de partir un
chimiste du québec nous a expliqué
comment faire des prélèvements
avec des tampons aseptisé et du solvant
nous cherchons des résidus sur le
matelas la tête du lit le plancher et
même dans le climatiseur
nous ferons analyser ces échantillons
dans un laboratoire à notre retour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'hôtel la réceptionniste a eu comme
consigne de ne pas parler de la mort des
deux canadiens mais il finit par nous
raconter que le premier matin qu'une
femme de ménage était allé cogner à la
porte de la chambre des filles audrey et
noémie aurait répondu oui
ce qui voudrait dire qu'elle était
encore vivante le mercredi matin
la réceptionniste ne nous en dira pas
plus le père de cette version le jeu du
matin tas de paniers pape a demandé s'il
voulait le charme nos hôtes nuit et le
vendredi matin et a déconné apporta peut
demander si vous voulez la chambre notre
nuit
[Musique]
le premier mercredi matin notamment
lille et man karl bélanger tire ses
conclusions à partir de ces discussions
avec la sûreté du québec qui fait
enquête dans ce dossier sont menteurs
entre 3h30 du matin entre 3h45 du matin
et salama
j'ai défini
le métier de l'infirmerie de koh phi phi
a été une des premières personnes à
entrer dans la chambre des filles après
leur décès elle ne peut pas donner
d'entrevue mais elle nous dit qu'elle
n'a vu aucun signe de violence seulement
de la vomissure
le soir nous retournons au var où elles
ont passé leur dernière soirée la police
exige un certain calme ce soir là il n'y
aura pas de danse et le signe du bar est
fermé
personne ne veut nous dire pourquoi ni
depuis quand
convaincu que nous n'en apprendrons pas
davantage à couper pis nous repartons
pour kravis c'est dans cet hôpital que
les corps de noémie et audrey ont été
amenés l'urgentiste nous décrit l'état
de décomposition avancé des corps
lorsqu'il les a vus naître
[Musique]
nous pensons mais juste la façon que la
taille larmes ont procédé ok ça ça amène
aussi le premier crime c'est que lyon
pau vers la saeta troisième journée avec
un groupe rappelle avoir attendu si
longtemps
le deuxième qui crime c'est d'avoir tous
ces décors dans un coin pas tandis
décompose en cinq jours les canadiens se
sont cachés quelque chose je trouve que
c'est cacher quelque chose parce que
quand rien nous reprocher long qui
dépêche au contraire de vouloir savoir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé soutient il le
faut savoir ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
ça nuise à notre tour ici c'est en
thaïlande
il y à une enquête policière le
responsable refuse de nous en parler
selon ce que nous dit l'interprète de
cette hypothèse où ask you no uta où sql
vallée non tout a commenté ce qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle aussi canadiens abc
[Musique]
nous retournons à l'hôpital de krabi le
directeur réfute la thèse des pesticides
j'ai entendu dire que ce pourrait être
un insecticide utilisé pour éradiquer
les punaises de lit qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
je pense que si deux personnes avaient
été infectées par un insecticide et
d'autres aussi leur ait été normalement
personne d'autre nike facture par la
présence de pesticides
ils avancent l'hypothèse des champignons
magiques symbolise certains touristes se
consomme des champignons magiques comme
ça leur procure des hallucinations
contre eux si vous en mangez trop ça
peut vite changer
je connais assez bien mes filles j'ai
pas parlé du tout là dessus mais là ils
vont me dire l'eau sont décédées de sol
non non ça je dois bréchet maison
[Musique]
après la pause la thèse défendue par les
autorités thaïlandaises contester les
concentrations de descons me retrouver
dans les deux jeunes parents
ça ne correspond pas concentration
toxiques encore moins une concentration
qui pourraient être mortels
[Musique]
devant toutes ces hypothèses
nous nous rendons à bangkok c'est ici
qu'a eu lieu le top 6 le pathologiste
nous apprend qu'il vient de terminer son
rapport il ne donnera pas d'entrevue
mais il accepte de nous dévoiler ses
conclusions des résultats étonnants que
personne n'avait soupçonné selon le
rapport thaïlandais les deux canadiennes
auraient été intoxiqués audit un produit
chimique contre les moustiques
le médecin a analysé le sent le vomi et
la bile il a retrouvé chez audrey une
concentration de dit de 15,3
microgrammes par litre chez nos amis de
33,7 microgrammes par litre
au moment de notre rencontre le
pathologiste et landais soutient que ces
doses sont fatales que penser de ces
résultats
comment peut-on avoir dû dit dansant le
médecin de bangkok a émis une hypothèse
la plus probable selon lui il ya un
cocktail très populaire chez les jeunes
dans le sud de la thaïlande
on l'appelle 4 par 100 il est composé de
coca cola de sirop contre la toux de
feuilles de kratom et de dit
le métier nous explique que ce cocktail
donne le même effet que l'alcool qu'il
est très populaire chez les jeunes
thaïlandais musulmans dont la religion
interdit l'alcool on serre les quatre
personnes comme les autres cocktails
dans des seaux de plage les bocket comme
on les appelle ici
viviane se souvient d'en avoir partagé
un avec audrey houdré pu moi on a bu
dans les bacs est donc assez de l'alcool
ronnie cooke ou quoi que ce soit qui
mène dans des espèces de sow pour favre
comme pour faire des châteaux de sable
puis rempli sofac deux intendants c'est
est-ce que vous avez partagé la même
boîte de partager la même boisson au
dream mon ami qui le brésilien si tout
le monde a vu la même chose ce soir là
comment expliquer que seulement deux
personnes soient mortes
viviane n'a même pas été malade ou
reviennent à la main loin on se rappelle
qu à ce moment là ça devait être autre
chose que de ramène co mais je me
rappelle plus eu un breuvage qui
ressemble à ça il nous explique en
thaïlande un sud de la thaïlande il ya
un cocktail qui est très très populaire
est composé de coca cola de feuilles de
kratos quelques pouces la base de sirop
pour la toux et de dit là ce qui serait
passé c'est que d'après le médecin pas
intentionnellement on aurait mis une
trop grosse dose de dit dans le cocktail
ça c'est arrivé je peux pas vous dire
parce que c'est ce qui est bien quand ça
s'est passé ça serait les deux seuls qui
aurait pris cet acte-là qu'avait eu trop
de dégâts et les mêmes réactions jours
pour rentrer en même temps mes mains je
comprends pas la coroner ni roussel
responsable de l'eau toxique se fait au
québec n'y pas d'accord avec les
conclusions du rapport thaïlandais et ne
donnera pas d'entrevue mais selon elle
les deux soeurs bélanger n'ont pas été
tués par le dic le directeur du centre
antipoison du québec va dans le même
sens avec les dosages où les
concentrations de dès qu'on a retrouvés
dans les deux jeunes femmes ça ne
correspond pas à des concentrations
toxiques encore moins une concentration
qui pourrait être mortelle et comment on
aurait pu avoir cette cette
concentration là dans leur sens on
pourrait très bien avoir ce genre de
concentration là après s'être appliqué
du détour la peau comme bien des
touristes dans ces pays là pour éviter
de se faire piquer par les moustiques
nous avons contacté à nouveau le médecin
thaïlandais qui a fait l'autopsié
il reconnaît finalement que la
concentration de dit retrouver n'est pas
si élevé selon lui le deed se seraient
évaporés en partie avant le top 6
selon le dr blais rien dans la
littérature scientifique ne démontre que
la concentration de 10 dans le sang
diminue après le décès
[Musique]
lors de notre rencontre avec la
coronaire elle nous dit qu'elle est sur
plusieurs autres pistes mais ce qu'elle
ne nous dit pas c'est que cinq jours
avant notre rencontre elle a fait saisir
nos prélèvements que nous avions envoyé
pour analyse dans un laboratoire
la coroner justifie cette saisie en
disant que ce matériel est utile à son
enquête pourtant nous avions convenu de
lui transmettre nos résultats cette
saisie a pour effet de bloquer notre
enquête nos prélèvements ne sont
toujours pas analyser et nous ne pouvons
pas poursuivre cette piste pour
l'instant
tantale enquête du coroner au québec
trois mois après le décès des soeurs
bélanger les brésiliens n'avaient pas
été interrogé par la sûreté du québec et
la coronaire vielles à peine de demander
aux parents de lui remettre les effets
personnels des filles utilisé pendant le
voyage
la crème des parents c'est que comme
dans les autres enquêtes on ne sache
jamais ce qui a tué leur fille qu'est ce
que vous allez pas je ne sais pas mais
je veux pas revoir
vous dites vous êtes parent je peux
avoir vos enfants première page des
journaux qui s'y est arrivé la même
chose
le mort ne sera pas ne servira à rien
malheureusement pendant ce temps les
morts mystérieuses s'ajoutent
quelques semaines après le décès de
noémie et audrey une américaine et une
canadienne sont mortes au vietnam dans
des circonstances nébuleuses
il s'agirait d'un virus dans un cas
quant à l'autre aucune réponse
[Musique]
ce qui fait que depuis 2009 dans cette
région du monde
douze touristes sont morts subitement
un point en commun la plupart des femmes
jeunes et en santé
les causes toujours inconnues
les enquêtes locales toujours bâclé
cachetons quelque chose pour ne pas
nuire au tourisme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
radio canada conteste devant les
tribunaux la saisie de ces prélèvements
prix en thaïlande
dès que nous serons en mesure de les
faire analyser nous reviendrons avec les
résultats
quant au décès des deux soeurs bélanger
nous en apprendrons peut-être davantage
lorsque la coroner déposant son rapport
dans quelques mois
après la pause en quelque sorte
milliards engloutis dans les paradis
fiscaux dans les grandes entreprises en
toute légalité
un des problèmes c'est que le canada
signent des conventions fiscales avec
des paradis fiscaux
[Musique]
en cette période économique difficile
plombée par la dette tous les états
cherchent une façon d'augmenter leurs
revenus et de réduire leurs dépenses
mais nos gouvernements aussi songer à
regarder en direction des paradis
fiscaux comme les barras ou le
luxembourg où les impôts sont minimes
un chiffre illustre bien l'ampleur de la
situation
l'an dernier les grandes compagnies
canadiennes ont investi dans les paradis
fiscaux
près de 140 milliards de dollars enquête
sur des pratiques des grandes
corporations de plus en plus contesté
[Musique]
le cirque du soleil n'a plus besoin de
présentation ce spectacle alliant
créativité ou à sa critique font courir
les foules partout dans le monde
le cirque est devenue une véritable
multinationale 90% tir revenus
proviennent de l'étranger augmentent à
l'intérieur de chaque multinationales on
trouve plein de petites filiales
souriante et qu'on fait passer l'argent
de la filiale canadienne à la filiale
dans le paradis fiscal
et miracle une déduction fiscale
apparaît comme beaucoup de
multinationales
le cirque utilisent des paradis fiscaux
pour réduire sa facture d'impôt un truc
consiste à déclarer un maximum de
profits dans les pays où l'impôt est
faible il est impossible dans les pays
comme les etats-unis et le canada
les comptables et les avocats des
grandes corporations sont aussi des
virtuoses de véritables contorsionniste
de la fiscalité internationale des
femmes ou un problème c'est la pression
qu'on les avocats et comptables et
fiscalistes remplir leur feuille de
temps puis vente des qualifications
fiscal de toujours de plus en plus sexy
bienvenue dans le monde de l'acrobatie
fiscale
[Musique]
le cirque du soleil c'est plus de 4000
employés et 32 production présence sur
cinq continents le soleil jaune du logo
de cet empire du divertissement ne se
couche jamais en langage d'affaires le
soleil est devenu une marque et posséder
une marque de commerce connu partout
dans le monde
ça vaut des millions de dollars nous
avons donc voulu savoir qui est
propriétaire du nom circule soleil
surprise en consultant les registres des
marques de commerce avec le monde on
s'aperçoit que le nom appartient à une
obscure filiale qui s'appelle cirque du
soleil il dit basé au luxembourg
pourtant le cirque n'a jamais fait
spectacle luxembourg des dizaines de
compagnies sont domiciliés à la même
adresse
il faut réaliser que ces compagnies ne
sont pas des entités ray il n'existe que
sur papier
ce n'est pas une vraie place d'affaires
avec les employés souvent ce n'est
qu'une adresse et un compte en banque
l'avocat américain jack g dirige
l'organisation tax justice network
ils dénoncent depuis des années la
facilité avec laquelle les
multinationales peuvent jouer avec les
règles fiscales est en national vous
prenez votre marque de commerce et vous
la vendez vos filiales incorporé dans un
pays où les coûts est très bas cette
filiale facture ensuite vos autres
compagnies qui utilisent la marque dans
les pays où l'impôt est élevé vous
réussissez donc à soustraire tout cet
argent à l'impôt de ces pays
on
voici comment ça marche supposons que le
cirque du soleil facture une de ses
filiales aux etats-unis un million de
dollars pour l'utilisation de sa marque
de commerce
un million de revenus disparaissent donc
je radar du fisc américain 6e millions
de dollars passée directement aux mets
de la compagnie canadian il lui faudrait
payer un impôt de 25% sur ses revenus
e
[Musique]
et si ce même millions est plutôt envoyé
au propriétaire de la marque
luxembourg les pros passent de 25 5,72 %
la compagnie canadienne peut ensuite
rapatrier l'argent au pays sans payer
d'autres impôts au canada parce qu'il
existe un traité entre ces deux pays
le canada devrait signer des accords de
non double imposition avec des pays qui
ne sont pas des paradis fiscaux avec des
pays où afp de l'impôt évidemment le
problème c'est que un des problèmes
c'est que le canada signent des
conventions fiscales avec des paradis
fiscaux
difficile de savoir combien de millions
le soleil tu économises en impôts de
cette façon c'est une compagnie privée
et plus de renseignements sont
disponibles
des représentants du cirque nous ont
confirmé utiliser ce système lors d'une
rencontre mais ils ont refusé de nous
accorder une entrevue sur le sujet il
insiste toutefois pour dire que ces
stratégies sont parfaitement légales et
même encouragée par le gouvernement
canadien
c'est la loi qui est scandaleuse le
scandale c'est que le parlement à ottawa
et le gouvernement washington permettent
tout ça c'est ça le scandale que tout ça
soit parfaitement légale le cirque du
soleil est loin d'être le seul à jouer à
ce jeu le journaliste denquête jesse3
que ai découvert que la compagnie google
a transféré les brevets de son moteur de
recherche aux bermudes ce qui lui a fait
économiser 3 milliards d'impôts en trois
ans le new york times publié en avril 4
enregistré une grande partie des ventes
réalisées à partir de son populaire site
itunes dans une filiale au luxembourg
ces techniques sont de plus en plus
répandue toutes les compagnies
pharmaceutiques et de technologie
américaine nous font c'est pourquoi à
leur taux d'imposition réel c'est à dire
le taux qu'ils paient réellement sur
leurs profits se situe généralement et
sous la barre des 20%
lorsqu'on visite un des nombreux paradis
fiscaux présent dans le caraïbe
on remarque rapidement que le canada est
bien présenté
entre autres des cinq plus grandes
banques canadiennes possèdent des
dizaines de succursales difficile de
justifier pourquoi ces banques ont une
telle présence dans des pays qui ne
comptent souvent que quelques centaines
de milliers de beats à elle seule la
banque cibc déclare détenir 10 9
milliards de dollars en actions dans les
caraïbes
yep autant d'opérations commerciales qui
justifie que la cibc aurait à prêter ou
à investir autant d'argent
en fait ce qui arrive c'est que ces
investissements vont dans les paradis
fiscaux c'est nécessairement dans les
paradis fiscaux que ça profite
les paradis fiscaux comme les caïmans
sont de véritables parasites
l'argent y rentrer en ressort
instantanément en pressant un bouton
de cette façon on peut écrire dans les
livres que l'argent est détenu dans le
paradis fiscal
même si en réalité il se trouve dans une
banque à toronto new york ou à londres
ils ne font que siphonner l'argent des
pays industrialisés et permettent à une
poignée d'avocats être comptable de
vivre la belle vie sous les tropiques
la cibc réplique qu'elle brasse beaucoup
d'affaires dans la région depuis son
achat de la banque locale first
caribéenne et les autres banques
canadiennes finance bien sûr certains
projets dans les caraïbes
mais l'explication de beaucoup
d'investissements à l'ombre des palmiers
se trouverait dans les avantages fiscaux
la banque scotia selon ce dernier
rapport financier
elle a payé un taux d'imposition
effectif de 7 %
donc il est pour beaucoup de citoyens
qui paient 7 % d'impôt sur le revenu non
freight pauvres
nous n'avons pas accès aux déclarations
d'impôts sûrement très complexes de ces
corporations
mais nous avons demandé la fiscaliste
brigitte alepin d'examiner pour nous les
derniers rapports annuels des cinq
grandes banques canadiennes et il ya
découvert que les banques dévalue même
le montant d'impôt que les économise en
gardant ainsi une partie de leurs
profits hors de portée du fisc canadien
la palme dans cette catégorie va bien à
la banque scotia
il est écrit le bénéfice de certaines
filiales étrangères est assujettie à
l'impôt uniquement lorsqu'il est
rapatrié au canada
si les bénéfices à distribuer et de
toutes ses filiales étrangères étaient
rapatriés les impôts à payer au 31
décembre 2011 s'établirait à environ 935
millions $ sur l'addition des chiffres
on s'aperçoit que les cinq géants
bancaires canadiens ont évité de payer 2
milliards et demi en impôts en 2011
en utilisant des filiales étrangères
cela explique en partie pourquoi malgré
des milliards de dollars de profits ces
banques paient proportionnellement moins
d'impôts que la moyenne des entreprises
canadiennes au canada il ya pas juste
des multinationales 97 % des entreprises
sont des pme et les pme sont assujettis
à des taux d'imposition beaucoup plus
élevé que 7 et 9%
au canada le même système permet aux
multinationales étrangères qui font
affaire ici de soustraire des millions
de dollars à l'epo hors du canada
poursuit glaxosmithkline depuis qu'elle
a découvert que sa filiale canadienne
vous à disparaître ses profits en payant
des milliers de dollars en trop à
d'autres filiales de glaxo incorporé
dans un paradis fiscal
la cour fédérale a donné raison ou
physique et la cour a dit que c'était
tout à fait inappropriée et de ses
profits auraient dû être imposée au
canada le problème je sais que les
autorités fiscales ne peuvent se battre
de cette façon avec toutes les
entreprises qui font ça la cour d'appel
fédérale a renversé cette décision et
donné raison à glaxo plus de vingt ans
après les faits reprochés
la cour suprême a finalement entendu
d'affaires l'hiver dernier il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensent que tout ce
système de transactions artificielles
entre filiales est impossible à
contrôler ce système est basé sur des
hypothèses de transactions théoriques et
les règles qui s'appliquent à ces
transactions sont plutôt floues
beaucoup d'argent canadien circulent
ainsi discrètement à des milliers de
kilomètres du pays
ici à zurich en suisse nous sommes
tombés sur cet édifice anonyme dans un
quartier résidentiel en regardant les
noms des 30 entreprises qui loge à cette
adresse
on reconnaît plusieurs grands noms
canadien sunrise cnn bridges and cana et
canadien pacifique
si vous et moi prenons de l'argent de
notre poche gauche pour la mettre dans
notre poche droite on n'a pas le droit à
une déduction fiscale
ça ne devrait pas être le cas pour ces
compagnies n'ont plus le phénomène est
rendue si important que lorsqu'on
regarde la liste compilées par
statistique canada des pays où les
canadiens investissent plus plu à
l'étranger on s'aperçoit que dans les
dix premières positions se sont occupés
par des paradis fiscaux
l'an dernier 141 milliards de dollars
canadiens au pris le chemin des paradis
fiscaux
oh
la loi reconnaît à tous les
contribuables
le droit de diminuer au maximum leur
facture fiscale le cirque du soleil
souligne que ces économies d'impôts lui
permettre d'investir plusieurs millions
supplémentaires ici au québec est de
donner de bons emplois à des milliers
canadien ces dépenses génèrent à leur
tour des taxes et des impôts ou pays
le circ estime aussi que ces stratégies
lui permettent de rester compétitif ci
dessus du soleil guy laliberté entend
parler que son compétiteur ailleurs fait
l plein d'occasions fiscale s'en va pas
prendre une journée qui y vont sont
comptables sont fiscaliste va recevoir
un coup de téléphone qui va se faire
comme ça se fait moins chaud comme ça se
fait que tu ne fais pas faire c'est le
pic ailleurs ils font le fondateur du
cirque guy laliberté pourrait-il
renoncer à ses stratégies
certains estiment qu'ils n'en mourrai
les moyens le magazine forbes évalue sa
fortune à deux milliards et demi de
dollars
est ce que une multinationale qui veut
conserver son image publique
bon en 2012 ou en 2013 2014 2015 pour le
21e siècle
est ce que c'est une façon de penser qui
durable et moi aussi tendance à penser
que man
avec la crise des finances publiques qui
a fait que la plupart des pays
industrialisés
plusieurs considèrent aussi essentiel de
resserrer les lois pour mettre fin cette
délocalisation artificielle des profits
dans les paradis fiscaux
si les taux d'imposition sont trop
élevés on peut les ajuster mais il faut
cesser ces petits jeux il faut réformer
le système fiscal pour que tous les
contribuables soit traité également
mais cette solution nécessiterait la
coopération de tous les pays de la
planète
jusqu'à présent toutes les tentatives de
négociations pour y parvenir ont échoué
si vous voulez nous contacter consultez
notre site internet à l'adresse suivante
vous pouvez y faire vos commentaires et
aux suggestions et revoir le reportage
pour connaître notre démarche
journalistique que je vous invite à
consulter mon blogue
veuillez prendre note qu'en quête et
rediffusée le dimanche à 18 heures sur
le réseau de l'information
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine à enquête
à qui profite le plan nord
hydro-québec en droit des contrats aux
autres acteurs
faut faire baisser la tension il va
l'octroyer va parce que c'est mal
nécessaire pour aux autres d'octroyer
des contrats aux attentes et ils n'ont
pas le choix
rihanna tombe bien mieux qu il
travaillait tu penses à un projet de la
romaine y en a pour six millions qui
nous propose
si des millions pour nos temps ci pour
se faire entendre de cette unité d obéir
important aux niches et nient tous des
québécois et des blancs qui profitent
son jeu pour l'assistant begag - en
dehors des sorties garania là dedans la
merci d'avoir été là
bonsoir la semaine prochaine
[Musique]